pakistan suffers from the worst floods
in more than a decade at least a
thousand people have died in two months
of torrential monsoon rains how much is
climate change to blame and can the
country cope with the resulting
humanitarian crisis this is inside story
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm rob
matheson now although monsoon rains are
an annual occurrence in pakistan this
year's deluge has caused the most
destructive floods in most people's
memories some provinces have received
more than five times the average
rainfall since june
climate change minister sherry hermann
has called it a climate-induced
humanitarian disaster of epic
proportions she says more than a third
of the country could still be submerged
after the monster monsoon season ends
more than 1 100 people have died 15
percent of the population is affected
half a million homes have been damaged
or swept away bridges and roads are
destroyed and people were running out of
food and drinking water
kamal haider has more from the swat
district in northern pakistan
well the aid hasn't started arriving in
some of these remote regions
because the road networks are badly
affected the bridges are gone
the landslides have blocked the road
and there are hundreds of tourists who
are still stuck
in upper swath we've been seeing
military helicopters
going to and fro to bring those people
out
many still remain in those areas
and also the situation downstream is
getting worse
we're told that about 336 000 q6
and now is now flowing at norshira
and of course the people that we spoke
to here in swath said to us
that this is four times bigger than the
2010 disaster which affected almost 20
million people
we also saw that hundreds of hotels have
been washed away
obliterated there's no sign
that there was indeed a hotel in fact
the raging torrents have brought big
rocks and those rocks have acted as
grinders
decimating everything in its path
however the good thing is that people
were able to evacuate
despite the fact that this happened
late night at about 2 a.m
at night however the people were able to
get out now we are told
that people have been cut off they need
help they need food they need medical
supplies and of course the biggest
challenge will be to start rebuilding
those roads provinces in the south are
bracing for more flooding as water flows
down from the mountainous areas in the
north foreign aid has started to arrive
but the government says it needs more
funds zembasravi reports from the city
of soccer in the southern sindh province
along with a rising death toll there are
a countless number of people who have
been injured in these floods there are a
countless number of people who are
suffering from
water and born waterborne illnesses and
and all kinds of skin diseases and there
are countless displaced by the
floodwaters that have been wreaking
havoc across pakistan now here in sindh
province one of the worst affected where
humanitarian relief aid is the most
needed where the highest number of
people have died and continue to suffer
from this crisis while there is help
coming while there are international aid
packages and airplanes arriving with
much needed aid it's not coming quickly
enough a lot of people that we've met
here say that they cannot wait by the
side of the road for help that they
cannot wait and possibly die before any
help arrives they're packing up they're
moving into places like sakkar like
other larger population centers and they
are looking for help themselves they say
the least they can do is take up some
kind of manual labor some kind of work
so they can earn a little bit of money
to feed their children people truly
hungry people truly thirsty and they say
they feel like they're on the brink of
death so the circumstances here are very
serious here in sucker at the edge of
the indus river it is clear that the
river is getting bigger the water is
flowing and the river is swelling and
the waters from the north are headed
this way so the worry for people here in
sin province now is
what will arrive first the humanitarian
relief that they desperately need to
stay alive or more flood waters
zane vasravi for inside story
okay let's bring in our guests in lahore
we have dawar but he's an environment
policy analyst also in lahore is sarah
hyatt she's a lawyer specializing in
climate change policy and in islamabad
peter oppoff who's the head of
international federation of red cross
and red crescent societies in pakistan a
warm welcome to you all peter i want to
start with you i know that you've worked
in several different countries dealing
with situations like this in preparation
for them how does this situation in
pakistan compare with what you've seen
before well first of all thank you so
much for having me on the on the program
um yes indeed i have been working for
the red cross present for a long time
the situation we see here now in
pakistan is i would say unprecedented
we have been working in many flood
operation or earthquake operations
the floods here are really devastating
and the force that it has
people were clearly not
prepared i would say for such a thing
nobody can be prepared for such a
weather event
and the impact is is huge it's huge and
this is something that
we will see for a very long time to come
the situation is very dire in pakistan
dawa pakistan has faced severe floods
before it's had extreme weather on on
both sides of the scale if you like
this is something significantly
different what is different this time
well uh for starters uh i think one of
the significant things that we've seen
is the change in the patterns of the
monsoon and this is this has happened
over the last three four years uh the
monsoon has shifted towards the south of
the country and an increase in rainfall
patterns where the natural drainage does
not allow the water to go out it just
accumulates and you have these massive
areas about 10 percent of the country
and this is specifically for the south
of the country where 10 percent of the
entire landmass the country is under
water so it's significant it's
what is being said is that it's similar
to the last 2010 super floods but in
terms of the concentration of issues
it's largely the south of the country
sarah even if pakistan and the
authorities had enough warning of what
was coming is there really much that
they could have done to try to
ameliorate the situation and at least
ease it for some people i know um i
don't think i think there's a knee-jerk
reaction to sort of start blaming the
government when something like this
happens but for pakistan the kind of
floods that we're experiencing
even though we had warning that floods
were coming and at some level perhaps
the government was also preparing for it
but i don't think we could have prepared
for what we are seeing right now
um especially like because like davor
said the monsoon rains have been
unprecedented we've experienced uh
generally pakistan gets about four
cycles three to four cycles of monsoon
rains and this time we're getting around
eight and we're probably going to get
more also um and that said uh so and
there are a bunch of reasons why why the
floods are so extreme this time and i
don't think the government could really
have prepared for this kind of
catastrophe and destruction
you say that there's a bunch of reasons
can you just run through what those
reasons might be in addition as you say
to the the climate change that has been
experienced yeah absolutely so think of
it like a pyramid if you're found of
reasons
and the foundational reason i'd say is
climate change um with climate change
with global warming
uh your clouds your clouds can hold more
water vapor which means that when they
leak this torrential rain and which is
why there's more erratic rainfall
around and uh spread across diff and
spread across larger regions this time
and then of course changing weather
patterns because of climate change which
means more monsoon rains more torrential
rain and then we have glaciers so
pakistan or this region of the of the
world we host the third largest glacial
ice mass in the world after the north
and south poles and with climate change
because glaciers are melting um and
receding we're seeing a lot of flash
floods we're seeing a lot of glacial
lake outburst floods and and all that
water is coming down south into the
country um and then on top of that
uh
and so the so this is like the first
layer would be climate change amongst
the causes the second i'd say would be
poor developmental planning and and i
believe we are to blame entirely for
that really we've been making uh we've
been building we've been constructing on
river banks and river shoulders
basically just obstructing the natural
flow of water and what and and nature
will win in the end and that's what's
happened so um the kind of destruction
that we're experiencing is is part and
parcel because of poor uh development
planning because of permits to build in
areas or that are sensitive to flood
there's been a lot of farming on flood
plains um that shouldn't have been there
to begin with and then other reasons for
the impacts of these kind of floods are
of course
governance challenges a constant uh sort
of
strife between the center that's
islamabad and provinces and who's going
to be responsible and um a lot of sort
of um
there's a there's a
it seems like there's a um a lot of
government departments will keep
shifting burden to other government
departments and sort of shirk
responsibility i think that has done a
lot to harm in flood relief efforts and
in preparing for the preparation of
floods and that said the political
instability over the last couple of
months in pakistan has definitely
definitely exacerbated the situation for
us the nation has been so occupied
between
the political sort of
has been so occupied and so polarized
between political parties and the
upcoming general elections that our
priorities were amiss maybe and and i
say this there's a huge maybe but maybe
had our priorities been more aligned we
could have prepared better for these
floods darwin the monsoon usually is
vital for agriculture and for the growth
of crops and the income of course for
millions of farmers um given the the
scale of what we've been seeing how much
of an economic
impact is this going to have on the
farming community in pakistan which of
course is is one of the key elements of
the country's economy so initial
estimates uh paint a very bleak picture
there are a billion dollars worth of
crop losses
uh nearly a billion when you billion
more when you consider livestock and
tractor losses because those are key
inputs or key ownerships within the
farming communities and then of course
uh the crop that was standing it's not
just that's been damaged for the next
three to four months this is a period
when the wheat crop is sold in october
the synth province has the wheat crop
soon which is uh then harvested in
february and march
that won't be done this year it won't be
possible to bear the land by then then
there is a cycle for the sugar crane
crop as well the cotton crop which is a
big big need for the country because
we're a textile manufacturing country
uh you have these huge textile mills
that need that crop will now have to
import that as well so when you put all
of that together along with
infrastructure losses in which our homes
roads bridges the minimum initial
assessment says five to eight billion
dollars
and uh this is just the immediate damage
when you think in terms of
rehabilitation when you think in terms
of uh getting these lands in order
getting the existing canal system to
work because it's been in it's been uh
badly damaged as well whenever you have
dikes being broken when you are
in places the
entire barrages have been swept away uh
their small dams have been swept so it
will take a long while uh
and uh to just to give you a sort of uh
estimate from 2010 when it didn't rain
this much it was largely a riverine
flood uh the estimate or the end of what
the
flood commissioner of the government
came ahead with was 40 billion dollars
worth of losses
so
pakistan was already as mentioned it's a
political crisis and it's also in a
situation where the economy has been
doing poorly uh we have a current exit
and all of that together is uh becoming
a big big problem if you look at the
near-term future peter i want to ask you
about the amount of responsibility that
organizations like yours are having to
carry in this situation um
sarah was making the point earlier that
nobody could have been prepared for the
scale of what was happening least of all
the government although
whether or not they actually knew it was
coming how much of a burden is falling
on organizations like yours compared to
the level of response that you're seeing
from government organizations
no i would i wouldn't really call it a
burden because i think a burden is a
very negative word as well
what what we do as humanitarian actors
and organizations is working with
governments working with communities uh
to make sure that people are better
prepared for it so and that is our role
um yes of course we would rather do
other development programs of course
because that would mean that actually
everything works perfect but it is the
the preparedness that we are working
with with the communities that we also
work with the government what to do as a
disaster risk reduction
what to do in case of a disaster how do
you respond uh for example how do you
do first aid everybody learning first
aid but also like if there's a flood
what is the reaction that you have to do
how do you get to higher grounds if
there's earthquakes what do you do so
and then that is the role that we play
and
again it has nothing to do with uh
people are prepared or not prepared as
this as my colleague panel members also
said this was unprecedented there's
nothing you can do about it
it's and it is indeed a combination of
rain and and
the warming of of of the earth and then
the melting of the eyes on the glaciers
so it is a combination of
but we are humanitarian actors
humanitarian organizations are there to
assist and we do that uh whatever it is
so now for the for the crops um as being
said lots of crops have been lost
areas are still inundated and it will
take a long time it might take weeks
months before all the water has uh
receded and that means that crops are
completely lost so what we do as fair
crossfit crescent is actually coming in
to assist the people as well in their
livelihoods
in our appeal that we just launched for
pakistan
we do have a cash component in it but
actually is to assist the people in
their livelihoods to start small
businesses to buy tools to buy seeds so
the moment that the water has receded
that they can start planting again of
course we're getting towards the winter
now but we we help wherever we can and
what we can do
sorry i referred earlier to the climate
change minister sherry raymond she's
also been quoted as saying we need
better planning and sustainable
development on the ground we need
climate resilient crops as well as
structures
that makes sense but this is not a
situation that pakistan is new to it has
suffered this kind of thing before why
hasn't this been done before why hasn't
uh flood relief been done before
sustainable planning not been done
before well both because as i say the
situation in pakistan is to a certain
extent not new despite the fact that
this is on an unprecedented scale the
one would imagine that some effort would
have been made to bring in the methods
that
sherry ramon is talking about and yet
she seems to be suggesting that it is
taking something like this to put the
thought into people's heads
what she was suggesting is that pakistan
needs to constantly sort of prepare for
and adapt to climate change which is
something we're doing to the best of our
abilities but at this point i think now
that push has come to shove i really
must say it out loud we aren't really
responsible for climate change pakistan
isn't we're just on the receiving end of
its impacts really
and which is why these floods have
become are feeling so personal to us
because um we contribute less than 0.8
to global greenhouse gas emissions
that's literally negligible
and yet look at what's happening we've
lost more than a thousand lives since
june
um 33 million people are affected one in
seven pakistanis is sleeping uh outside
in the open
and um
literally houses livelihood livestock
almost 800 000 livestock have died and
um
like we've been talking about i'll
reiterate i don't think we could have
prepared for these floods i think what
we could have done is maybe we could
have had better early warning systems
maybe we could have had um evacuation
plans ready and yes i think that is a um
it's poor calculation on the part of the
uh um provincial uh disaster management
authorities and the national disaster
management authority however if if you'd
like me to talk a little about what
pakistan is doing for climate change we
are i want to stress we are doing
whatever we can with you know with the
political instability and economic
instability and the kind of population
we have with the fifth most populated
country in the world sometimes for the
government climate change is on the back
burner it shouldn't be i'm definitely
not saying it should be but it does
happen it just sort of slides to the
back but we are investing in making
climate resilient or rather water
climate resilient seeds so to spe so to
speak uh crops that will grow in saline
forgive me for interrupting you because
i want to pick up on something that you
have talked about i want to ask dawah
about this sarah is making the point
that that has been recorded in several
places that pakistan's
contribution to global uh global climate
change is actually percentage-wise
very very small
why is it do you think that uh other
governments of other countries which
produce more of an impact in
on the climate seem
um if not unwilling then certainly um
not in a position to be able to help
pakistan in situations like this or in
the preparation of situations like this
because if pakistan's having a minimal
impact and they're having a more
significant impact one would have
thought the burden
should out of responsibility should
actually lie with them
sana's also already mentioned this and
she is completely hundred percent
correct that it feels very personal
when we talk about the terms of in terms
of impact uh
just to give you an idea the entire if
you put the entire population of
australia on one side and you look in
just the people affected we have more
people affected right now and
when talking about responsibility
pakistan is
bearing the brunt of all of this at only
1.2 degrees that's a global average and
in the 2010 floods mean the average was
about one degree increase now even a 0.1
degree increase means for pakistan that
entire monsoon pattern can change
it will switch its existing paths from
centuries ago but for just a little bit
of every change so this is what we
really need to talking about that the
emissions of the entire globe
have to come down and maybe even 1.5
degrees is untenable for pakistan what
happens at that point if we are going to
touch 1.5 which is the goal with these
net zeros targets which is the gold
buyer for uh 2050 targets for a lot of
countries that it is an accepted norm
that we're going to touch the global
leverage of 1.5 or even exceed that that
will mean that for millions of people in
pakistan and countries like pakistan
there will be no shelter they will they
will have to evacuate year after year
and when we talk about evacuation plans
and everything where do countries like
pakistan put 33 million people there's a
it's not possible it was
simply not feasible for countries like
us to prepare for such a big big big
calamity it's of course governance
failure if when we talk about pakistan
being vulnerable or being among the top
10 most vulnerable part of its our
preparedness part of it is governance
part of it is state capacity and
investments employment resilience but uh
if pakistan simply does not have the
resources
we would badly spend those resources if
we had
none of those resources are available to
us or have been provided since the paris
agreement i want to bring in sarah there
forgive me for interrupting you but i
want to bring in sarah because she was
anxious to make a point there
yeah i just wanted to i just wanted to
build a little more on what daover is
saying he's absolutely right but i think
but the more important thing right now
is like he's saying we are going to be
this part of the world global south and
the subcontinent even bangladesh india
pakistan afghanistan we're going to be
experiencing very high temperatures if
climate change isn't controlled or
rather global warming isn't controlled
and we that means more exacerbated
floods that means we will be get we will
be seeing floods maybe worse than these
ones and what the government really
needs to do and i would like to tie in
with your point about why sherry ramon
really hasn't why the government hasn't
prepared for climate change i think it's
pertinent absolutely essential that we
start preparing now today
for you know for
floods that will be worse than what
we're seeing right now these floods are
worse than the 2010 super floods the
next floods could be worse than this i
want to bring in peter here because he's
quite anxious to make a point let me
just ask you peter given the scale of
everything that we have been talking
about are you concerned that
organizations like yours will simply
reach a point where they cannot cope
well
it's difficult to say i think uh so far
we have been able to cope over the many
years uh that we do exist and each and
every time we do adapt uh to the
situation and that is what we have to be
as humanitarian organizations we have to
be flexible we have to adapt to the
situation uh yes
you can see it and asari also said that
the situation is getting worse 20 20 10
mega floods and the 2022 floods it's
much worse what is going to be next and
can we deal with it
and at the same time we also have to see
like 22 floods now today comes at a time
when we the people and the communities
were already very vulnerable we had uh
we went through the whole profit uh
pandemic which put a economical
burden to everybody to governments but
to the people themselves as well so
people are vulnerable already so it
isn't adding up to and yes
are we are we reaching a point that we
cannot deal with it anymore i do not
think so in all the years i have been
working in the maternity sector we
always manage to deal with it it is an
effort but we do
uh we do deal with it and also we are
getting better to a certain extent
because technology will help us better
we can do more with with less that we
did uh earlier on well the point that i
wanted to make as well the discussion is
like climate change end up pakistan
actually are very low but has the big
burden of the whole climate change and
and the disasters the impact of it
i think instead of pointing fingers yes
we have to deal with that we have to
really have to uh go to the west and say
look look you have to do more to stop it
but i think what we have to do now with
these slots um
2010 compare what have you done in 2010
how did we cope with the 2010 floods how
do we cope with 2022 floods what have we
learned from 2010 to 22 how do we can
how can we do better and i do believe
talk to my
colleagues here in the office that have
been very much involved in the 2010
floods we have learned a lot we have
actually have better uh systems in place
to respond and to actually keep peter
i'm very sorry i am going to have to ask
you to stop there i'm afraid we have run
out of time but i appreciate you very
much for being with us thank you to all
our guests
sarah hyatt and peter off and thank you
too for watching you can see the program
again anytime by visiting our website
aljazeera.com
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story
you can also join the conversation on
twitter our handle is at aj inside story
from me rob madison and the whole team
here goodbye for now
[Music]
you